mehenni mes amis mes amis mes amis je
viens d'avoir au téléphone notre grand
leader thierry ardisson oui ne vous
réjouissez pas trop vite il est tombé en
panne de voiture dans le bois de
boulogne où il s'était rendu pour des
raisons professionnelles je répète pour
des raisons strictement professionnel
thierry ne pourra donc être là ce soir
avec nous en direct au studio bonaparte
et nous allons faire l'émission en
duplex téléphonique
il ya juste un petit problème il faut
que les téléspectateurs ne se doute de
rien c'est pourquoi je vous demande et
d'afficher sur vos visages soit un
sourire niais soit une mine au centre
soit encore pour les plus doués d'entre
vous un rictus angélique le
téléspectateur moyen comme vous le savez
est idiot et il se laissera berné comme
un enfant par ce stratagème génial voilà
d'ores et déjà pour vous détendre je
vous ai composé un petit bout rim et qui
je crois résume assez bien la situation
ne laissons pas paraître notre désarroi
pour ne pas compromettre notre déjà roi
[Rires]
syfy déjà roi vu que thierry ardisson et
royaliste ne pas vous allez dans les
circonstances difficiles
un brin d'humour ne fait jamais cet
homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever le
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher de
zapper et conserver son hardy matt il
est prêt à tout tous les moyens sont
bons même la qualité
[Musique]
blais
pas
[Musique]
non
avec question who danièle gilbert
claire chazal qui lui sert le professeur
voilà le président lorrain le chat d'oc
et moi
alors professeur oui thierry oui mais je
fais mon bon soit ici ou quoi la fête
votre bon soir normalement thierry
puisque tout est normal hein pas vrai
les amis mes facettes messieurs bonsoir
bienvenue au studio n'a pas pour mardi
matin avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet je voudrais vous dire que comme
toute émission qui se respecte
nous allons vous offrir des cadeaux des
tas de cadeaux
ce soir vous allez vous partager son
téléviseur si mme chaya télé commande
vocale pour gagner il suffit d'appeler
le 47 28 02 47 pour élire votre télé
potiche préféré parmi les cartes que
nous allons vous présenter tout au long
de l'émission les 100 premiers seront
donc un teaser type seriate et les
commandes vocales
les 1000 suivants recevront la cassette
du film al khaliq de spike lee qui sort
cette semaine sur nos écrans c'est quel
film qui sort cette semaine thierry
malka mik
[Applaudissements]
alors professeur et bien à thierry comme
il est désormais de tradition un petit
bilan de la semaine dernière la séquence
qui a le mieux marché et la semaine
dernière c'était la séquence jesse
jackson et ça c'était votre ip et la
tyrie vraiment en six émissions 6 idée
géniale vraiment on peut dire que vous
êtes ce qu'on appelle un magicien de la
télévision mais cette semaine tout
magicien que vous êtes j'ai bien peur
que vous ne parveniez pas à trouver une
idée du même tonneau
t'es trompé mon professeur âgée troupes
et j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé là je me suis
dit est-ce que janet jackson n'aurait
pas mon chéri mais comment vous est
venue cette idée géniale
j'étais au restaurant avec ma femme et
un seul coup en regardant ma femme il un
pasteur mais qui a un frère je me suis
dit c'est janet jackson aurait pas comme
ça que j'ai trouvés près des îles vous
mangiez quoi ces indiscrétions et 4 et
agneaux prometteur 10 restants génial où
il entend adopter s'il vous plaît la
terre attac 2
[Musique]
oh
et
après le jackson de la série après le
coin le tchèque souffre de la faim oui
oui tu as bien et avant de continuer la
tradition voudrait venir un petit moulin
à vent particuliers et des chiens
devient s'attendent à écouter que
thierry non mais attends attends d'état
d'état n'est vraiment ça ne va bras on
vous entend trop mal les téléspectateurs
vont se douter de quelque chose il
serait préférable que vous veniez nous
rejoindre en studio 1
je serai pas l'avant avant dix minutes
un quart d'heure moi bah on va meubler
thierry foncé foncé pour déjà riche
d'accord excusez moi excusez moi j'suis
désolé monsieur le professeur rollin
mais là franchement les téléspectateurs
mais adhérents vont pas comprendre
non non on aurait coûté une paye leurs
redevances sur des contribuables
honnêtes pour la plupart ils ont voix au
respect ou alors à ce moment-là que que
la chaîne publique met en place un
service minimum je n'étais pas qu'il ya
un présentateur de garde mais ça encore
une fois il y aurait des speakerines ont
respecté les horaires ça n'arriverait
pas mais enfin c'est toujours bon d'en
parler mais à l'isi mon cher président
du point de vue ça permet de faire
quelque chose à gagner du temps on va
respecter les horaires pour une fois je
crois que ça peut être pas mal bon eh
bien écoutez vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à nous rejoindre chaque semaine
pour regarder hardy matt pour ceux
d'entre vous qui n'ont pas vu les
émissions précédentes
nous allons maintenant vous proposer en
attendant l'arrivée de notre grand
leader
un résumé des épisodes précédents
kerry et animateur sur la télévision
publique ça n'est pas tous les jours
facile car il doit faire de l'audience
mais sans oublier la qualité
heureusement le professeur rollin lui
donne ses conseils de spécialistes
en face d'eux le président lorrain se
croient tout permis car il représente 18
millions de téléspectateurs
thierry reçoit ses amis du showbiz et de
la jet set
[Musique]
pendant ce temps son vieux copain corti
est prêt à tout pour se faire embaucher
mais thierry adam
du passion car ils cherchent la télé
potiche idéal et son coeur balance
elles sont aussi intelligente
thierry arrivera-t-il à sauver la vie de
zap qui serais tu es si la part de
marché de l'émission descendait en
dessous de 15% à suivre
alors thierry la wii où on vous attend
ce maquillage professeurs oui mais
écoutez manier vous un peu le popotin
comme disent les jeunes
parce que là l'audience commence à
baisser sérieusement j'ai pas besoin
d'envoyer des chanteurs chanteur oui
ouais ouais j'suis pas des femmes de
chanteur ah oui déjà des femmes de
chanteur mais laurent lantieri
tant qu'à faire de la femme de chanteur
fait donc de la femme de chanteurs morts
savait que les chiffres montrent que la
femme de chanteur mort fait six fois
plus de points que la femme de chanteur
voici fans de santé remords
il faut
un jeu
soit
[Musique]
- co
thomas
j'ai des photos
bien sûr
[Musique]
m
et
sur le sable
les yeux dans l'eau
mon rêve était au bout
l'été qui s'achève
il partira
où
à son milieu
comment tu aimais
tu t'en vas
nous
en tant pays doivent il ya une petite
erreur là dans votre séquence femme de
chanteurs morts
roch voisine son mari n'est pas mort ah
bon ah non pas au temps pour moi
alors mon petit savent comment ça va mon
petit à pune déjà six hardy matt et il
est toujours là qu'est ce qu'on dit aux
téléspectateurs
on dit merci merci merci parce que
l'audience n'est jamais descendu en
dessous de 15%
il veut pas mourir on utilise à poney oh
non non non non non non non non je veux
pas mourir avant qu'ils aient tous ne
veut pas mourir et pas mourir milow pas
mourir tu as entendu parler des
philippines ont ils à poney c'est ce qui
leur font là-bas au chien d'audience non
seulement il les tue non plus il les
mange mais ça arrivera pas ici parce
qu'ici les gens ils vont regarder hardy
matt jusqu'à la fin ah oui ça m mais à
dire vous regardez jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'à la fin oui oui oui oui comme les
etats-unis le japon et la france avec
hardy matt l'émission désormais fameuse
de thierry ardisson
les philippines ont leurs chiens
d'audience a battu si la part de marché
descend en dessous de 15%
mais là bas la coutume veut que ces
chiens soient mangés par les
téléspectateurs sur les marchés
[Musique]
l'échangé je tiens à m'excuser pour les
légers débordements lors de la
précédente émission j'ai été un petit
peu loin et je tiens vraiment m'excuser
auprès de mes adhérents la fin la
semaine dernière à la fin de l'émission
oui j'ai été un petit peu enfin bon
c'est maintenant parlons plus merci
monsieur ardisson ou là un petit peu de
champagne au ballon rond vraiment une
boîte à outils font parce que j'ai fait
a effectivement un petit peu succès fou
c'est ça la télé c'est ça fait donc
monsieur ardisson au delà des
revendications habituelles de nos
adhérents qui concerne je vous le
rappelle le retour des speakerines le
respect des horaires
la présence d'un présentateur de garde
et oui et oui au delà de ces
revendications habituelles je vous
rappelle que la semaine dernière vous
vous étiez engagé auprès de moi pour
faire votre possible afin que danièle
gilbert retrouve sur nos écrans la place
qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû perdre
alors monsieur ardisson où en êtes-vous
car je vous le rappelle en toute amitié
en tout respect un geste de moi et 18
millions de spectateurs de
téléspectateurs zappent et pas sur tf1
ou sur arte
voici danièle gilbert
[Musique]
danièle gilbert bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue sur le plateau d'art du mat
merci de m'accueillir c'est avec plaisir
première question faut-il coucher pour
réussir dernière non non attendez
attendez le faire d'ici là je pense que
ce genre de questions n'intéressent
absolument pas les téléspectateurs
en tout cas mes adhérents je crois que
l'heure était donc des spectatrices a
peut-être été spectatrice à ne savent
pas effectivement donc alors moi je
crois que les gens de questions
intéressantes à poser d'allibert c'est
par exemple daniel gilles madame
danielle mademoiselle danièle gilbert
est ce que est ce que vous retournez
souvent à chamalières par exemple
oui c'est intéressant pour la télévision
ça moi je trouve ça passionnant
alors va pas souvent n'ont pas souvent
non vous ne voyez pas trop souvent votre
famille
eh bien vous vous trompez pas ce que ma
famille est près de chez nous près de
chez moi maintenant près de paris ah
voilà alors ça voyez rays intérêt ça
c'est intéressant
danielle secco acteurs plus sexy non non
monsieur andré dirrell toutes façons
d'abord d'abord effectivement mais je
crois que ce genre de classement c'est
lui que j'ai pu c'est ici à côté de moi
merci madame
[Applaudissements]
pasqua dans le sexe daniel est venu à
moi je veux rien parce que je crois
qu'effectivement encore une fois le sexe
n'est pas la chose qui passionne le plus
les téléspectateurs en tout cas mes
adhérents
en revanche à une question qui je crois
sur l'a50 nos adhérents ils sont très
très très télé sont et les télés un sexe
non télé ils sont telle est donc la
question middlesex à la télé très peu
très peu très bas il ya des rectangles
blancs fanion n'a pu malheureusement
c'est un petit peu triste mais enfin bon
faut pas non plus être trop passéiste et
n'a pas non plus et hardy matt hahn hon
j'amenais ya pas de janis non plus hard
au nom du besoin
alors donc la question je crois qui
intéresse tous les téléspectateurs et
mes adhérents particulier c'est cher
daniel est ce que vous pensez bientôt
revenir à la télé et cher daniel
deuxième question en une voyez en une
deux questions chères daniel est ce que
est ce que vous êtes très contente de la
sortie de ce compact disque laser
je suis pas maso donc je suis très
contente de sa sortie du compact laser
avec des poèmes mis en musique
et puis deuxièmement on peut répondre à
la première partie de votre question je
vous dirais que c'est pas très
intéressant parce que c'est pas à moi de
répondre c'est aux décideurs
moi je suis pour être un jeu comme les
scouts j'adore la télé toujours
alors cher daniel puisque je vous
appelle daniel en après un terrible et
représentent 22 millions de
téléspectateurs oui on est obligé de la
voir alors jacques amiel
je voulais vous offrir au nom de nos
adhérents ne corrèze cette pendule qui
saura vous dire que pour nous il est
toujours eu leur que vous reveniez à la
télé
et
sèmassi comme vous le savez désireux de
conforter son audience par une présence
féminine
harvey matt a lancé la semaine dernière
le premier grand casting de thé les
potiches en france après s'être a cogné
une pré sélection cette semaine
elles reviennent pour un examen pratique
composé de quatre épreuves toutes plus
difficiles les unes que les autres
installations
[Musique]
alors maintenant des mets
sur alors antonio stop ou d'abord le
parcours sophie favier destiné à tester
le déhanché de la télé potiche est ce
que tu peux s'il te plaît vas-y le
déhanché la potiche très bon deuxième
epr le décrocher de téléphone à la
lawrence de sacrée soirée
là tu décroches étudie bonsoir vous êtes
en direct dans hardy matt l'émission de
thierry ardisson
bonsoir on est en direct dans hardy matt
l'émission de ferrières me sens très
bien en tenir
troisième épreuve de tourner deux roues
à l'américaine avec sourire commercial
vas-y antonio bien alors que nous
maintenant dernière épreuve le rire
spontané à la julie de cheyrou casse
assieds toi croise les jambes tout et
les potiches voilà tu me dis j'ai fini
j'ai fini fois le zizi pas mal
tout le monde
les retouches à la première candidate
s'il vous plaît si vous voulez bien
monter votre prénom
stéphanie bonsoir ça va vous vous sentez
ça va ça va est en forme wii en forme
vous connaissez le parcours sophie
favier vous pouvez nous montrer un petit
déhanché sur le paf on s'assied favier
alice m'a très bien est ce que vous nous
faire un décroché de combinés
téléphoniques à la lawrence de sacrée
soirée s'il vous plaît évitons soir vous
êtes en direct avec thierry ardisson
dans hardy matt bien le bonsoir monsieur
dupont oui bonsoir vous êtes en direct
dont un imac émission de thierry
ardisson quoi nous faire un tour n'est
drew à l'américaine avec sourire
commercial s'il vous plaît
je m'attends asseyez-vous la dernière
épreuve
comment rire spontané à lajunie de
cheyrou casse dites moi j'ai fini quoi
logistique
non c'est superbe c'est super vous
referiez ça tous les samedis sensible
oui surtout avec vous thierry très bien
elle est pas mal mais ça heureusement
elle n'a fait que 50 sur la route un peu
président lorrain c'est bien c'est frais
c'est technique c'est grand public je
trouve c'est bien moi je trouve que
rentrée qu'elle a fait ça toute sa vie
ouais tu mettrais combien toi sur
combien avec des sur vingt dix ans erna
tu mettrais 16
non non non c'est pas l'école des fans
là tu vas pas commencer maintenant mais
tout seul ça peut pas être l'école des
fans bon d'accord c'est 16 très bien
merci en a plus
vertement à tanis parcours sophie favier
matin et un peu rapide devrait pas leur
faire un petit sociaux lentement un peu
plus dérangé c'est bouclé
[Musique]
tu sais
allô monsieur dit pour vous êtes en
direct le suivre hardy vat l'émission de
thierry ardisson
bien l'arrêt est pas mal à ce niveau
vous me dire j'ai fini je le disais
c'est pas désagréable côté un peu sévère
espagnol professeur thierry à je ne sais
plus que vous aviez une réponse toute
trouvée
[Rires]
à combien je mettrais 12c plus austère
tout merci on l'appelait
alors je m'appelle valérie valérie petit
déhanché
monsieur vous êtes sur un smash à
l'émission de thierry ardisson
j'ai eu de votre réponse à l'énigme que
nous avons posée tout à l'heure et bien
très bien vous avez gagné
[Musique]
m
professeur je dois préciser que l'énigme
en question était quelle est la couleur
du chien blanc de thierry ardisson un
président très très bon le sens de la
création littéraire très très bien moi
je trouve qu'elle n'est pas du tout
réservé elle est par an ferme et du tout
ouais très ouvert sans bien aux 13 13
[Applaudissements]
ouais
alors les impressions très bien
dominique c'est quoi ce plan là c'est
rien bon allez bon soir
oui ferries votre tentative est très
louable d'amener dans cette émission une
présence féminine mais il y a eu notre
présence qui fait défaut si j'en crois
la structure classique des feuilletons
américains
c'est une présence noire et oui je crois
que j'ai ce qu'il vous faut professeur
vous allez voir un black qui chante
black is black
qu'est-ce que je peux faire de plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais non parce que là un noir qui
chante noir c'est noir c'est trop de
noirs il faudrait du noir à 80% de
dilution dans le blanc voilà ce qu'il
faudrait un blanc qui chante noir c'est
noir qu'est ce que je peux faire de
moins
noir c'est moi
du coup
je n'avais plus d'un
jamais
je
non
de gentils
m
oui
oui oui mais là non plus non plus parce
que la dilution est bonne mais il manque
20 % de petite blonde stupide
voilà c'est ça qu'il faudrait pour
équilibrer un noir et une blanche qui ne
chante pas noir c'est noir qu'est ce que
je peux faire d'autre
résident
je trouve que c'est un très très beau
sujet monsieur édition bravo très rare
et mais simplement à ce propos je suis
en train de me demander ce qu'est devenu
gillett à eau
la très jolie speakerine de couleurs
j'aime je crois vraiment que les
téléspectateurs ça les intéresserait de
savoir ce qu'elle est devenue
renseignez-vous c'est pas si on peut
faire quelque chose non 1
ouais ouais ouais vous y travaillez
ouais voilà vous mettez votre équipe
dessus ouais
sinon 18 million spectateurs qui semble
non non non merci d'abord merci au
président merci monsieur vers 10 ans je
voudrais maintenant vous parler d'un
film formidable intime qui sort cette
semaine sur vos écrans un film dont on
parle trop peu
c'est ce qui s'était déjà passé à
l'époque de batman et c'est dommage ce
film malcolm x du jeune réalisateur noir
américain spike lee n'a fait que cinq
couvertures de mensuel tous couverture
hebdo et sa bande annonce n'a été
diffusée que 27 fois cette semaine à la
télévision
comment voulez ces conditions qu'il ait
sa chance auprès de ses spectateurs
potentiels
alors pour permettre à malcom x de spike
lee de rencontrer enfin son public
nous avons décidé d'en diffuser un
extrait fait pas n'importe comment au
ralenti pour lui donner le temps
d'antenne qu'il mérite
voici malcolm x voici malcolm x
[Musique]
effrayant factuellement sur tous les
écrans dans les visiteurs voici notre
deuxième invité christian bujeau
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir et merci de cet accueil
aussi courtois que chaleureux merci de
la part de toute l'équipe d'être venu
sur le plateau d'art d'imad je sais que
tu che rare à la télévision
oui c'est un choix est ce que on va
commencer par un parent un extrait des
visiteurs oui en volontiers oui à eux
aussi n'ont pas fermé le robinet n'est
pas capable de fermer les robinets
timbre et jacquouille échanges
oui mais qu'est ce que c'est
la pression
je pense qu'il serait quand même
perplexité les autres acteurs du film
celui mange allait commencer par saria
une bonne actrice je trouve pas très
connu mais qui fait le rôle de taille de
ton épouse s'appelle le mans valérie
lemercier valérie lemercier
ouais c'est pas mal adorable on sait
merveilleusement entendu je dois dire
une chose c'est un scoop ce soir dans un
rond mais on m'a dit aujourd'hui
justement la télévision je trouve ce
matin que certaines personnes pensaient
que elle était ma femme brûlée dans la
vie et que j'étais dire également
dentiste novices et c'est faux on sait
mais heureusement entendue mais elle
n'est pas ma femme dans la vie je vais
jean-marie légèrement ou ce n'est pas
mal
elle est formidable et le petit qui est
si drôle là il s'appelle comment clavier
christian christian clavier il est pas
mal mais il est bien aussi wii n'a pas
été trop déçu par jean marie poiré le
réalisateur ce nom est bon non j'ai pas
été déçu du tout parce que c'est un
directeur d'acteurs c'est une à sira et
on s'est bien régalés vraiment le
tournage ça s'est passé comment ben ça a
été un petit peu à un bon un joli fous
rires c'est vrai c'est vraiment un
moment délicieux jeu des projets oui
j'en ai d'ailleurs avec christian
clavier
oui j'en ai alors tu sais que tu es rare
à la télévision c'est pour ça qu'on en
profite et un petit peu de ta présence
pour deux pour te demander comme on
demande souvent la télévision aux
acteurs
quelle est ta position sur sarajevo
c'est une question qui demande une
réponse rapide et je vais la faire juste
incroyable comme ça se passe à 1000
kilomètres d'ici oui oui c'est
incroyable j'ai une réflexion là dessus
les gens qui sont massacrés sont des
musulmans et les pour l'instant les
musulmans se manifeste à propos de rouge
dit je croise et le level encore tué le
responsable des versets sataniques mais
on les voit pas du tout bougé pour entre
guillemets leurs frères
c'était étonnant c'est ça aussi qui
était étonnant voilà merci questions et
à bientôt j'espère pour nous
il apparaît que dany blanchet là bas
là tu l'as pas du tout la mairie n'y en
a pas
c
hastings petit robot
consternation
bonsoir votre prénom
sylvie s'élever services et des civils
oui c'est branché s'élever olalalala
peut leur faire s'il vous plaît encore
une fois c'est une fois
décochez combiné téléphonique on sort
monsieur dupont ben oui je dors chez
l'art du madih mention de clients du
soir
vous aimez
[Musique]
attention à pas en baisse
comme aimait
[Applaudissements]
il
posez vos gens et vous me dis chiche
wallonie
quant à mes patients suivis de cheyrou
cassin et j'ai remarqué que tel le
vaisseau du désert elle marche l'embl
sur les tapis président écoutez je n'ai
pas grand chose à dire c'est très sentie
c'est très spontané ça va te manque un
peu de précision monsieur tellement donc
moi je trouve que s'il dit apprécie
beaucoup la plaisanterie finale qui est
quand même très subtil mais quand je
vais lui mettre une bonne note
combien 17 et demi au mercy
[Applaudissements]
reprenant hélène hélène vous connaissez
les preuves numéro un
[Musique]
pas les mains et fo
le crochet téléphone
allô monsieur [ __ ] vous êtes en direct
sur un du marché nous sommes terrés à
gruissan vous avez perdu
chevrette et les petits chats vous allez
tous vous avez commis
une chance vous avez inouïe voilà si
difficile alors r30 azéri peut-être
n'apprécie telle pas la plaisanterie oui
c'est possible et c'est les petits je
dois savoir rire aux plaisanteries du
passé ce que je me dis moi je reste
comme sophie favier comme laurence c'est
grave plein c'est très grave
est ce que vous regrettez au moins ça
arrange les choses
président c'est intéressant c'est qu'en
même temps il ya une certaine distance
ça me fait un peu penser à jean pierre
descombes
oui non sans quoi savons point que
finalement il n apprécie pas trop mal
bon bien 18
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourtant le petit prénom shannon un
petit déhanché jeunes projet pilote de
l'écurie montfort vous êtes en direct
soir du matériel vous le plaisir de vous
annoncer que vous avez gagné pas mal
pour les deux roues
[Musique]
c'est vous j'en ai tous là c'est fini
daloz y accéder
le sol
peu de créativité à la télévision cette
espèce de rapidité de répartie qu'il ya
dans nos provinces mais ça me ravit
amaro fr3 côte d'azur c'est parfait
spécial mais moi tout ce qui est
provincial me plaît beaucoup combien 16
pression c'est difficile comme bako
quand même non ça plaisante faire ça
vous côté dominé qu'est ce que c'est que
ce plan dont les bons soirs merci
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs je
voudrais vous montrer des images
absolument incroyable d'un mais qu'est
ce qui m'arrive là il est bloqué dans la
mémoire de trappes gauche pour la
dégager
bloqué dans le coin chez soi c'est
compliqué c'est lé défi certes on l'a
surtout google local était marrant toi
t'as vu la gueule que j'ai en plus
[ __ ] ouais ces trucs là ça se bouge
tout le temps tu un coup de pompe et 5
passes aïe aïe sérieux qu'est ce qu'on
fait faut envoyer la bécanerie opex et
les mecs vous êtes gentil je vais quand
même pas y passer la nuit un [ __ ] t'as
vu ma gueule je sais pas moi démerdez
vous appelez la fêter les bonnes idées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
professeur chutes d'audiences
catastrophiques mais j'ai l'armé absolue
mais aussi des trucs qui en fait si tu
étais rien de dormir pendant toute une
nuit
[Applaudissements]
président oui pardon oui oui c'est bien
c'est bien j'ai bien aimé vous auriez
pas la même chose en couleurs et en plus
oui pas de problème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ces tuyaux reste de la bande aucune
idée
[Musique]
nous vivons précisément le genre
d'épisode que personne ne croit emerton
[Musique]
devra d'abord puis salé
à toi petit
[Musique]
amis
a plu
finito ya plus de cordes fans de
vraiment place s'il vous plaît bon y'a
attachant vous votre rallonge doit elle
vient sache que je les coupe et du
sommet coupé du sommet ça va de soit
mentir de la sorte si non mais oui mais
oui
apic la au bout que nous puissions
continuer notre descente en eau très
judicieux génial pourquoi n'y ai pas
pensé et c'est pour ça que lui c'est un
farouche et moi un euro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
résidant au président goût et oui elle
vous saviez pas un petit tout cas à
boire parce que il fait vraiment une
chaleur à crever ici pas de problème
des noms propres
j'essayais v8 5 avril
wade
[Musique]
on
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant le troisième invité claire
chazal
est-ce que ça t'embête quand on
t'appelle mais médéa est ce que ça te
remettes plus qu'avant c'est vrai que
lorsque tu prends l'avion maintenant tu
gardes les factures c'est pourquoi tu
ferais pas comme christine ockrent ou
anne sinclair t'épouserais pas un
ministère très bien merci
on applaudit claire chazal
[Applaudissements]
bon nombre d'entre vous ont été un petit
peu choqué par la coloration sexy de
notre émission beaucoup d'entre vous et
non des moindres s'en sont émus je tiens
à dire solennellement que je ne cèderait
pas aux pressions et que nous
continuerons
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon déjà très bien tu aurais rien de
répréhensible dans ce sujet c'est
parfait vous avez vu comment elle
s'était fourré la pâte à modeler ah bah
oui mais là non non la faute ferry dans
le sujet ça allait bien mais l'a fourré
ah bah écoutez si évidemment il ya une
acception ensemble d'arbustes qui ne
coûte rien mais il ya une autre
acception four et c'était là votre verre
transitif argotique baiser [ __ ]
[ __ ] et ben ça va vous coûter une
tranche de venise documentaires
culturels
je regarde le barème fourré forêt pour
efforts et 26 secondes mais aussi fleuri
que parfumer les palets reprennent leurs
fiers démarche
ivre de la beauté de leur propre image
qui se reflète depuis des siècles dans
le frémissement du canal pain frais et
voilà bien puni hockey à bout d'accord
casting de potiche trois installations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on y attend dit d'un ton
les volutes soutien avant même de
commencer votre prénom
stéphanie nous regardons votre des
hanches
encore encore
encore encore très bien le décrocher
annie gala laurence de cette manière
dix sept en direct chez hardy matt série
à 10 ans et vous avez gagné
oui
vous me dites j'ai fini poil au zizi
c'est vivant plaisanterie les cent pas
devant vous irez loin la télévision il
faut savoir rire quand le patron flynn
plaisanterie c'est très bien mais celles
ci ont pour ce qui est du déhanché
thierry je pense que sophie favier peut
aller se rhabiller si elle n'en a pas
pas de coucou c'est nous alors moi je
trouvais là on voit le pâté
maman j'ai peur tiré que vous ne
puissiez pas l'émission non j'avoue que
j'étais un petit peu trouble est à vue
oui j'ai vu ça fait des semaines et de
stabiliser 18 et nous voulons
[Applaudissements]
je suis bien qu'ils aient été la semaine
dernière pré sélectionnés en deux
secondes et demi oui absolument
malheureusement maintenant pas
malheureusement de ce été
présélectionnés j'ai pas pu parler
voilà ce soir vous nous parlez vous nous
dites votre prénom florentine florentine
bas je trouve que pour l'unité des
potiches déjà dire son prénom c'est
beaucoup la télévision désormais le
public est le seul juge
oui il n'y a plus d'autres jugent que le
public désormais vous savez alors vous
me direz j'ai fini positif à bon tout ça
[Applaudissements]
merci moisn que travailler sur une
chaîne du service public coûte erratique
en tout cas thierry si nous retenons
florentine il faudra rallonger le fil du
téléphone parce que sinon elle est si
grande que le téléphone pente à côté des
heures à genoux pour répondre président
elle chaloupe à merveille elle répond
avec entrain et pourrait presque être
animatrice est dangereux et thierry
wipff animatrice
c'est dangereux vous croyez où elle va
loin à yalta aux mannequins ou mannequin
d'aller ensuite note ben oui c'est
difficile parce que mannequin télé
potiche c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose vaut 18 18
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
le couple a nommé noël emmanuel on vous
regarde
alors madame dupont
bonsoir vous êtes en direct dans hardy
matt l'émission de thierry ardisson et
vous allez gagner une nuit avec thierry
ardisson
formé dans l'est
non mais
tourner une roue à l'américaine le
sourire commercial croiser votre gens
comme une vraie petite voix là et vous
me disais c'est si mal aussi
elle n'est pas bien au delà de tout
éloge pour ma part sur 20 je mettrai 641
résidents j'ai un mal fou moi je la
prends comme secrétaire pour les
testeurs
ben moi j'ai pas tout à fait les mêmes
critères que vous messieurs je mettrais
18 ans corbin
quelles sont vos impressions après six
épreuves c'est formidable moi je devrais
faire ça plusieurs appartements que le
samedi c'est trop peu une vraie vocation
de téléfoot
oui c'est mon rêve j'aimerais beaucoup
avoir le 7 d'or de la meilleure poitiers
ah bon face à ce que dans la
consécration ça risque d'arriver c'est
très joli
dominique est ce que c'est ce plan rien
corti le score sec de poulet pâtes en
acheter eu la mer a jeté une tête trop
fort patron parce que je touche la
dernière fois encore j'avais pas une
voix de fille mais là avec ça pour me
reconnaître il est fort le patron ouais
je t'ai dit philippe ya pas de place
pour toi danser tenir la caméra je suis
pas mauvais apparemment pas trop tu vas
y être deux trois plans qui sont passés
dans l'émission mais c'est parce que
réalisateur d'or sinon c'est un bon bon
bah écoute question je peux pas filmé
sur européenne belgique on en parlera
d'accord ou la roue allez on enchaîne
sur les appeler à l'aide
égide en où il voulait dire que moi
aussi je regrette énormément le départ
de monsieur corti comme je regrette du
reste le départ de casimir et de l'île
aux enfants
souvenez-vous ni nos enfants voici venu
le penser il fait des champs dans l'île
aux enfants c'est tous les jours
intense et le pi joyeux des enfants
heureux époux aujourd'hui vous êtes un
paradis ce jardin n'est pas loin car il
suffit d'un peu d'imagination pour que
tous tout près de vous pousser fleurs
sait lire et ses chansons voici venu le
temps des rires et des gens dans l'île
aux enfants c'est tous les jours le
printemps c'est le pays joyeux des
enfants heureux des monstres gentils
nice est un paradis
[Applaudissements]
bravo bravo au président lorrain je
repense thierry notre ami cortier veut
que tout à l'heure le bon vieux temps du
double jeu
c'est vrai que cette émission avait au
moins un avantage c'est qu'à cette
époque vous traitiez correctement les
invités alors que là je suis un petit
peu attristé de voir que maintenant vous
aviez tout à l'heure la chance d'avoir
christian du genou l'avait un peu
traitée au débotté
je ne sais pas ce qui vous arrive mais
vraiment vous les traitez comme quantité
négligeable
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'aille
leur servir la soupe aux invités c'est
ça que vous voulez professeur au moins
ça kerry se faire servir la soupe
d'accord marc quand tu viens fabien tu
viens
[Musique]
et
c
[Musique]
et
c'est parce qu'il n'arrivait vraiment
l'état des quantités négligeables
qu'est-ce que vous
j'avais resservir l'insup aux invités
en plaine il a fallu jacques soir son
soin bonsoir mes emmerdes
on est en retard on voulait choper la
sortie de scène et tout coûte en plus on
dit toujours que je traite mal mais
invité la junte avait amené les
souvenirs beaucoup de servir la soupe en
plus c'est pas l'air pas qu'est ce qu'on
va faire un jeu qu'on peut aller la
lambo berkeley alors à boire un coup
allez mourir je viens avec ta soupe toi
donc c'est la 150e 150e ouais mais tu
vas rester là jusqu'à quand là on va de
toute façon maintenant jusqu'à fin mai
et en juillet fois par semaine on fait
le mardi après midi à 15h30 paris photo
je vais dire tout le bien que je pense
de cette pièce se verra que je te ya
vraiment là sous vos moi j'adore ça
là on va écouter alors il ya un serveur
externe et axa fait oui à jacky c'est là
où je voudrais valais bonsoir soir
bonsoir
bon on la goûte cette soupe alors on va
voir
j'adore la souris s'est lui dit ça ne
pense pas c'est maxime venu pour servir
des sites mais celui qui servent à
souffler un peu de soupe
on dit que c'est pas sympa moi j'ai vu
la pièce hier soir et je trouve que
cette pièce donc elle est drôle dans son
aire pas une seconde en fin et je sais
pas si les gens enfin ciboure est
humiliant même si la 150e donc des pâtes
et mon problème mais je sais pas il faut
dire aux gens qu'on se marre qu'on
rigole que consomme a pas une seconde et
tout est est ce que c'est bien passé ça
ce que tu viens de dire si c'est bien
passé la façon dont il dit est ce que
c'est bien passé dans les médias est ce
que les gens ils ont dû suite royale en
costume diderot crébillon
c'est qu'elles sont pas dit que ça va
être un peu cyan et non parce que je
crois que enfin séparé répondait c'est
comment je trouve que tout ce qu'on a
fait justement c'était pour amener un
autre public
une saga qui yade au départ d'une pièce
quand une pièce commence il ya toujours
pendant 10 15 représentations le vrai
public des amoureux du théâtre
de toute façon les yeux fermés vient et
après il se répand dans tout paris pour
dire voilà comment c'est moins bien et
bien de guerre ou alors c est et en plus
cela il ya un miracle avec le marigny
c'est qu'il ya les trois sortes de
public
il ya ceux qui lisent les critiques il
ya ceux qui viennent par le bouche à
oreille et puis y'a des gens qui ont
jamais mis les pieds dans une salle de
classe qui viennent parce qu'il ya des
prix de places demi-tarif le mardi
après-midi ou parce que c'est des gens
qui justement n'ont pas le l'idée que
c'est du duc réunion dudit noah qui
viennent là comme pour dj lewis et c'est
ça c'est c'était le pari de deux ça
c'est violent de présenter un tas
rigoler oui non mais j'étais très très
très heureux ce monsieur on s'éclate on
défonce le fait bien 10 trop vieux ou là
à les regarder et suissa qui dit ça les
arrange fait presque rap il est vraiment
un
parce qu'il faut sortir de l'idée que le
que le théâtre réservé à une élite de
jeu c'est pas vrai
il n'y a pas besoin d'être cultivé pour
lire la bible il ya un besoin d'être
d'être cultivé de connaître la langue du
xviiie pour la comprendre
dutourd maire sait que c'est comme la
musique de mozart c'est aussi beau que
le rap c'est c'est simple et bonne la
soupe
elle est bassement moi je suis content à
se dire bon appétit mais ça les bonnes
merci alors tous les soirs après le
après le marigny vous venez ici c'est ça
soit on vient au berkeley selon vos val
d'isère il ya roland il ya tout le monde
sait le cadre extraordinaire ce qui tu
vois un truc de dingue wargniez que des
fautes ont sacré des toits alors
qu'étienne chez brésilienne quel effet
ça se fait qu'on met brésilienne quel
effet ça fait de se retrouver en train
de jouer du du club lions fils
c'est vrai qu'on m'a dit et j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer francis était la
seule brésilienne qui joue du crédit en
physique et peut être en intérim à 10,18
imessage de ma mère je crois qu'on en a
quelques-unes des fois frais du poète
fait plaisir à voir
non c'est vrai on a on sent une
complicité comme ça entre fait très
plaisir à voir c'est un vrai bonheur de
voir
c'est vrai
je vais y aller ou belle émission j'ai
pas pourquoi bas parce que ils
m'attendaient tracassait toi non t'as
plus rien ça va encore un peu je les
appelais la métallurgie nuées et en
magie l'on va jusqu'à fin mai je vais
retourner avec ma femme je les appelais
j'ai déjà vu la pièce et que c'était
très bien elle m'a dit mais la prochaine
fois tu ravec projet la victoire à
bientôt d'accord c'est normal c'est la
france ici
le bonaparte vous
les genres
[Musique]
allô allô ya quelqu'un
alors non
vous voulez dire que le numéro lavaud
pour gagner les ondes et les migraines
de malcom x
c'était pas le pont sli pas les mères
j'étais le garant vous êtes 28 nous non
françois je vais là encore professeur
47,8 sous tous blessés
alors je rappellerai dans un moment le
[Musique]
madame a
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux